special shout-out to pal walrus
petitioning the Wisconsin Teachers Union
now be called the Green Bay slackers now
let's talk Union thuggery okay before I
get into anything it's important to
remember the strange crazy concepts that
teachers should actually be teaching
children when they refuse to come in and
do their job it's really the kids wind
up getting screwed
boy if only parents could absolve
themselves of their responsibilities
like teachers I'm hungry oh I'm sorry
you you say you're hungry
huh well guess what when you grow up
you're still gonna be hungry only your
bill is gonna be cracking $100,000 a
year in salary benefits
so much so the teachers union in
Wisconsin are posting a bill that would
most notably require them to pay into
their own pensions yes pay into them at
all along with removing some of their
ever-expanding bargaining power to suck
more taxpayer dollars from the system
now it's important to note that once
upon a time unions played an important
role in America sometimes they were
needed to make sure employees were
treated better but as always power
corrupts and the bigger they got the
more they ended up screwing the actual
business owners those are our terms
right there okay but um you know the
company can afford this those are our
terms right I know but if you don't make
any concessions um we'll be forced to
close our doors and you all lose your
job I don't know nothing about that
those are our terms right there it's a
nice photo of your wife what do you mean
you lost your job I know right of course
in some instances like the UAW the
government steps in and bails them out
so the unions have to make few if any
concessions and the politicians get to
bide their votes oh yeah by the way look
up political contributions because
there's one sector that gives a whole
lot more than big oil or pharma and
virtually all of the Union contributions
go to Democrats now of course union
members in Wisconsin are also upset that
this bill
would allow people to opt out of the
Union what how does that a problem if
the unions are designed to protect the
worker then no workers would leave but
of course if some of those workers have
been strong-armed into joining then a
lot of them would leave out of their own
free will thereby dissolving the Union
let me get that for you so Scotty I hear
you haven't been paying your dues yeah
well you know it's just been a tough
strapped for cash well I hear you've had
all this money to go to Packers games I
ain't old peanuts and sodas yeah yeah
you know what some it's Billy's birthday
and you really like the Packers so you
know eight yeah we got a gun oh yeah
should probably pay your dues here's the
truth federal spending on education 1
adjusted for inflation has more than
doubled to over 82 billion in the 1970s
while test scores haven't improved at
all bumper stickers read that it would
be a great day when our school will get
all the money they need and the Air
Force would have to host a bake sale the
vive honors but total taxpayer
investment in education in this country
actually exceeds that of national
defense and over five hundred and thirty
six billion dollars in the Oh 405 here
alone schools aren't getting any better
but teachers unions are getting richer
richer off taxpayer dollars taxpayer
dollars that Wisconsin and the citizens
of America can no longer afford but what
do you folks think about Wisconsin the
American education system as a whole be
sure to let me know and I think it's key
to remember here folks that public
sector unions unlike the private sector
are actually unionized against well
against you go ahead taxpayer make my
day
[Music]
but seriously I need like three weeks
off and me